[Music]
the open plains of the asphalt jungle
[Music]
home to many creatures great and small
and the puffing ground for one of the
most clever and illustrious creatures
the plastic bag today we explore the
cycle of life for this curious creature
the plastic bag on its migration to its
home the Pacific Ocean once released
into the wild the plastic bag is unsure
on itself it falters at first but soon
with some help from the wind the bag
will be airborne this flight will be the
first in its long journey towards its
final destination the Garbage Patch in
the heart of the Pacific Ocean using the
wind to guided the plastic bag moves
across the city through the air
a city park this park may at first seem
an idyllic place for the plastic bag but
danger lurks around every corner here it
will encounter many enemies including
one of the most dangerous Park Service's
poor little fella looks like his journey
ends here meanwhile our little bag has
encountered one of nature's most deadly
killers the teacup Yorkie once the
Yorkie has locked onto its victim his
fellows will hope of survival but using
its superior size and deft maneuvering
our bag manages to escape the orcas
talons and flee for its life
[Music]
over the course of its miraculous
migration the plastic bag will cover
vast distances through neighborhoods
across parks and down city streets
it is now nightfall and our highly
advanced night-vision cameras have
managed to capture for the first time in
history a plastic bag in pitch black
phenomenal
vast cement rivers of California home to
literally dozens of animals many plastic
bags will not make it out of here the
reeds and branches will see to that
as at home in water as it is on land or
in the air the bags natural buoyancy
makes it an excellent swimmer
[Music]
it's closed now and it can feel it
at last the bag has reached the Gateway
to the open sea
careful to avoid the mouths of hungry
sea life that feed on the helpless
plastic the bag will travel hundreds of
miles to join the thriving community of
plastic known as the Great Pacific
Garbage Patch the garbage patches of
veritable plastic oasis where millions
of tons of plastic garbage remain
trapped by the currents it is said to be
twice the size of Texas never actually
biodegrading here the plastic bag can
live indefinitely peacefully coexisting
with billions of other petroleum species
before breaking into ever tinier plastic
pieces thus completing the plastic cycle
of life so what are we doing wrong our
scientists have been telling us for some
time that we are well along in an
extinction crisis a catastrophe that
nobody meant to have happen extinction
of species now climbing past a thousand
times the normal background rate you're
a fifth mass extinction as many of us
know as 65 million years ago wiped out
the dinosaurs and the worst mass
extinction a quarter billion years ago
wiped out 90 to 95 percent of the
species cause unknown today's sixth mass
extinction which is under way is caused
by humans are spreading this friction of
wild habitat disregard for all the
nonhumans those animals that don't have
our species labeled plants and our
flowing pollutants now rapidly is will
the rising man-made global warming in
which twenty and fifty percent of all
species will be extinct or committed to
extinction within the next 35 years so
many of us here have a good chance of
seeing them so I'll be your cheerful
moderator for the evening full of good
news as we hear from three great leaders
who can detail not only y2b alarm but we
are plausible and even exciting hope
look at the reality even exciting hope
may be found and action taken a little
later we'll hear from the woman who made
the virtual reality film collisions that
you just saw or can see afterwards
they'll still be here if you didn't see
before you came in and from an
anthropologist just back from the past
rising water in the Pacific but first a
different panel and that Natural History
film we just saw up here about the
perilous homeward journey to the Central
Pacific of the plucky little species the
lowly plastic bag so sensitively
narrated by Jeremy Irons is just one of
countless attacks now on our biosphere
well zero in on that problem from four
angles the sea the animals and their
minds what sustainability really means
and the human condition all the while
looking for possible plausible solutions
so our first panel I'm I'm proud and
pleased first to welcome a woman known
as a living legend the National
Geographic Society explorer-in-residence
she's an oceanographer and author
founder of mission blue the former chief
scientist at the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration NOAA she's
led more than 100 expeditions logged
more than 7,000 hours underwater
and set a record for solo solo diving
below 1,000 meters please welcome Sylvia
[Applause]
[Music]
prepare yourself
also in this event is an ecologist and
the first endowed professor of this
title nature and humanity at Stony Brook
University he's a best-selling author of
numerous books including song for the
blue ocean and his latest book beyond
words what animals think and feel please
say hello to Carol Safina an awful
chemistry joined by the director of
science at the Earth Institute Center
for environmental sustainability in
Columbia University where the motto is
ecology with no apology he studies the
ecological and environmental
consequences of the loss of biodiversity
please welcome to hit me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so so yeah
what was the last time you were diving
underwater I mean surely you don't still
go swimming done last time I was
underwater was this morning when I took
a shower the next time is next week on
the out in the Gulf of Mexico made of
two little submarines aboard the
research vessel of Lucia Dalia
Foundation and what would you be looking
for mentally well if I knew I probably
wouldn't have to go it's all about
exploration but truly we are looking for
the aftermath of the 2010 spill I'll be
in the company of cement enjoy who's a
scientist from the University of Georgia
has been tracking the fate of the
disaster for several years now although
ever since it occurred if you don't know
time job and you were one of the first
not just women but one of the first
people to put on a scuba scuba breeding
system and go into what a new so member
what that first felt like when the first
didn't know it was glorious being able
to breathe underwater and if you haven't
tried it don't wait any longer
really the blue part of the planet is
accessible to essentially everyone mask
fins snorkel scuba the increasing number
of submersibles available to the public
and by curiously of course you can do it
but there's nothing like jumping into
person I think no child should be left
drowning
oh you grown-up children too you
remember our first early moment of
amazement when you were down even
realize I can breathe oh yeah first it
seemed unlikely that you could actually
do this you know but it doesn't take
long you just get in and take a breath
and air is there and then it's it's just
a sensation of flying it's not natural
to us but what is natural mean but
breathing is natural and I think it's
just breathing underwater so one same
thing sorry yeah well what worries you
most about the conditions of this
complacency that people at large
generally they fail to understand that
our lives depend on maintaining the
planet pretty much the way it was when
we came along ten thousand or a hundred
thousand however long ago you want to
trace our history that's certainly the
world is not what it used to be I told
people I come from a different planet
and they they say yeah we knew that but
it's the planet I knew as a kid really
has changed we've seen more change to
the natural world in the last century
the last half century and even in the
last ten years the pace is picking up at
a rate that is unprecedented in all of
human history we have the technological
capacity to destroy to unravel the
systems that have taken all preceding
history to put the planet that works in
our favor
and we have undone it or at least were
well along the way to undoing it we are
changing the nature of nature but I
think not too late to turn it around a
nature you know imagine it trying to
have 7 billion people thrive on Mars
there's a great example of Earth without
nature without the systems that make our
lives possible if you haven't seen the
Martian check it out you know
you know where air comes from well the
Martian had to science it figuring out
how to make air out of rocks
how to find make food out of a handful
of potatoes and you know it's just we
take everything for granted and we think
earth is too big to fail and I think
10,000 years ago even a thousand years
ago even 50 years ago people maybe had
some justification for thinking that no
matter what we do earth will continue to
go on and be okay for those but we've
already had plenty of those signals half
a century ago it should have an awakened
us to the need for us to take carry o
that which keeps us alive our
life-support system that is built-in on
this planet but nowhere else in the
universe could we count
having such gifts ready-made for us and
for all the rest of life and discovering
them so many particles in Canada and
company we just saw there's nothing
interesting about the plastic that we
heard about can't believe everything I
saw the hell but I have come from the
pre plastic azoic era and so I know that
we don't have to have plastics
most of human history there were no such
things
Plastics serve us well I'm looking at
shoes that are probably plastic I my
computer there's a plastic parts and
buttons on my clothes but it's not the
times things that are the problem we're
the problem it's what we do with
plastics the idea that we have
single-use plastics that we use once and
toss and they wind up is a little film
that preceded this presentation
indicated so that image you just saw was
of me swimming in plastic suit in a
World Heritage Area 300 miles offshore
from the coast of Costa Rica near Cocos
Island the winds and currents have
gathered together this river of plastic
and it's obscene what we're doing to our
life-support systems the lack of respect
we have when one condition of the coral
ring thinking that headlines allotment
ly what you're feeling about that
profound sadness because I have been a
witness to the change died the coral
reefs that I knew when I began exploring
the ocean in the 1950s in that time
about half of coral reefs his beloved
places that are celebrated around the
world that form like a jeweled built in
the trafficking midsection of the planet
they're dead they have a they basically
are not gone because the skeletons are
still there but they're they died or
they're in a state of decline and you
may have been noted notice the headlines
in recent weeks about the state of the
not-so-great
Barrier Reef that has seriously been
affected over the years by pollution
runoff from agriculture that borders the
eastern seaboard of Australia and
ravaged by destructive fishing technique
it's not about fishing for saving
fishing has fit people and entertain
people perhaps as long as there have
been people but the large-scale
extraction of ocean wildlife has really
affected not just the fish but affected
the places they live coral reefs need
the fish that live there and fish need
the coral reefs and when either or
destroyed or taken away the other suffer
so
so what quickly causes the bleach the
bleaching the coral bleaching and why
does it matter I mean some people say
nature is always going and having these
ups and downs what's different why does
it matter
it's true the nature is always having
her ups and downs but we are the cause
of the downs right now cause of what is
driving this shift in planetary
temperature among other things but that
is clearly an effect climate change that
is the warming specifically puts stress
on whole categories of the corals that
make up coral reefs there many species
but there think they're tuned to a
relatively narrow temperature range that
is consistent in the tropics it has been
for a very long time but recently this
shift in the warming causes the small
plants that live in the tissues of the
coral to escape they just leave for
whatever reasons think they are expelled
by the corals and it's a symbiotic
relationship a partnership with the
algae and the Carnales again the carl's
need the algae the algae need the corals
and if you take the algae away it's bad
news for the carl's if you can inch of
corals away it's bad news for the algae
that live within the tissues and it was
just one other gem
sense of other fish stocks are not
living near the reefs what are the
numbers like from what they were before
there was a great human onslaught are
they are the numbers way down in many
species well we got really good at
catching even the wobbly from the sea
after World War Two in the 1950s the
amount of ocean wildlife extracted for
products and for human consumption was
no in the order of 20 million tons which
is a lot of wildlife from systems that
pre-human times have not known a
predator that was able to extract on the
scale that we were then taking but
consider how armed with new technologies
satellites GPS sonars you know they the
big deal is fish no longer have a place
to hide we can find them in places that
previously gave them protection because
of their inaccessibility so the numbers
that have been taken since the middle of
the 20th century have scaled up their
numbers have scaled down so on the order
of 90% of many of the big fish and some
of the little ones to have been
extracted 90% yep of the wines in the
ocean correct right and wildlife do you
like to eat tuna swordfish lobsters
oysters clams new things look at the
list do you eat fish and you soon do eat
fish not anymore I know too much and and
so what they've been eating and suppose
a person that has to just has to eat
Fisher there's some fish they should
never eat that are most in danger I mean
I love sardines and his tin with all of
Mormon humans a lot of choices you talk
to Carl about this too because he his
witness the same kinds of changes that I
had and you know I think
we can get away with taking some find a
place for ourselves within the natural
systems needs to take a lot of world
birds to used to take a lot of wild
buffalo to but we overdid it we've
overdone it
leave the wild finish to the point where
we're not you know it's not like
starting 50 years ago we're starting now
well it's hard for us humans who've
lived on the land and just look at the
great ocean to think that they matter
have feelings like fuzzy warm mammals
Carl do you think any kind of disregard
for the the actual animals themselves
that are called a fish has anything to
do with what's going on here it has
something to do with what's going on
we have disregard for almost everything
if we want to exploit it we have
disregard for people from other cultures
when we want to exploit them we kill
whales and disregard the fact that they
are milk producing mammals who love
their babies like we do if we want to
exploit them and if we want to exploit
fish we just say they're unconscious and
they have no feelings and can't feel
pain
can they yeah I think fish can feel pain
and they're they had they have pain
receptors they have they're probably the
distribution of the pain receptors is
different than it is with us they they
seem to have more pain receptors be hot
on them on the rear edge of their body
where they're more likely to be hit by
something then they do you know around
their heads and stuff like that but they
but they feel pain they certainly but
they certainly feel all the time that
we're attacking them is panic alarm
stress and shock so I bet you you know
that you can just clearly see by the way
that they're reacting but we have this
feeling of this great abundance of fish
from the sea for us humans what's well I
don't know why you have that feeling
because it's not really that way anymore
it's not it's not that way anymore I
mean when when I was born there were
half as many people as there are now and
many parts of the ocean that are totally
intensely exploited were you know barely
tapped at the time and now we have a
lock on more or less everything and
we've seen you know we've just seen over
the course of our lifetime things that
were totally abundant when I was young
or scarce now and a few things that seem
to be gone when I was young have
recovered but there are I would say that
the you know the overwhelming global
tendencies for some of these major
things we're talking about is that the
trends are extremely worrisome alarming
depressing distressing and entirely our
fault and we with those that we see in
the places where we have addressed the
problems we see that they show recovery
trends and there are some enormous
successes the predatory Birds that were
just about totally wiped out by DDT when
I was young and living in Brooklyn or on
Long Island
Ospreys peregrine falcons bald eagles
those things are very much recovered I
watched them fall apart I've watched
them recover now but now we're watching
really really big systems falling apart
also I think the scale the scale is is
different now it seems like just
entirely because I mean humans are
wonderful things you know we have a
sense of the universe we have a sense of
our place in nature this whole museum
has always been my Cathedral and and
that's great but we're too much of a
good thing Sylvia you still seem to have
some hope you have hope spot tell us
about those around the world that you've
designated
when we take action to protect species
turtles whales birds and single amount
for protection recovery may be possible
no guarantee there examples of failure
as well as success but it also applies
to ecosystems and places and we're in
the centennial year of national parks
what a great idea
it is often been observed to have
national parks so if a hundred years ago
it became put into you know system of
national parks and imagine if we had not
taken action on the land if we had just
left everything open to exploitation and
we had to start today to protect what
remained of whatever did remain in the
absence of care so imagine the ocean we
have a new chance in this century to
identify places that should be protected
because they can serve as sources of
restoration places that are still in
very good shape or places the Chesapeake
Bay that have are not in such good shape
but with care have the potential to
recover and so hope spots are a name for
places that in the sea but might as well
apply to the land as well caches ledges
rape offshore from where we're sitting
so there's no tell us about casual as
we're looking at a battle right now it's
just off the main is that right I took
the plunge and with to explore this
mountaintop and all those but not quite
reaches the surface about a hundred
miles east of Portsmouth they huh it's
fantastic there's a kelp forest 100
miles out in the middle of the ocean I
didn't know I attended a boston sea
rivers conference and some intrepid
divers followed the intrepid fishermen
out there to this this mountain peak
that is crowned with this luxurious
group
of kelp and it has attracted a luxurious
assemblage of cod lobsters of Wales it's
a paradise but the surface you can't see
it you just have to dive down about 30
feet and there it is but it slopes off
very quickly into hundreds then
thousands of feet into the depths of the
Atlantic Ocean below so it's a treasure
it's really an extension of Acadia
National Park just as happens to be
underwater every day in the newspaper we
read the horrible things recently these
climate scientists just three weeks ago
they announced from NOAA and National
Climate Assessment to research labs that
within 10 to 15 years global warming
will mean that oxygen is leaving the
ocean so fast that fish will be
struggling to breathe within 10 to 15
years and they see this why do you think
such admirable pioneers as these have
not yet been able to turn it around
because the news coming in is very bad
well it's it's a tough question they
answer but I think that the problem
actually spans many many scales from
those of us who care about the whales or
those of us who care about particular
species to those are concerned with
oxygen levels in the atmosphere in the
ocean and it's very hard for one
individual to work across all of those
scales and I think actually we have some
examples here pioneers as you said it do
go across them but I feel that you use
the word Earth's system I think that's a
problem that we're facing is that our
Earth's systems are changing
dramatically and that requires a sort of
holistic thinking that's that's hard to
do so I work on by adversity so I'm
always thinking about all eight point
seven million species at one time but
you know if I walk up to someone and
says well how are the Panda doing or how
are they how are the bluefin tuna doing
then you know Maya to reduce my
conversation to that scale because
that's what they're interested in so if
we can accommodate all of those
different interests from the system's
level
to the individual level where we can get
people concerned about individual
species or groups of species and about
natural resources but then also start
thinking about rebuy geochemical
processes the atmosphere ocean chemistry
and so forth then we'll get the kind of
thinking that we need in place learn
about the rest of you but I mean I
partly became an ecologist because I
didn't like chemistry now I have to now
I actually have to choose and I've
learned my lesson but you've introduced
us to it'll be an increasing problem for
us as we think about this the
extraordinary complexity of this problem
is holistic and we can't avoid the
holistic connections that we have to pay
attention to as complicated as the earth
itself well so that's that's an
interesting point of view because in
fact me because I'm a professor at a
university I encounter young people who
are definitely smarter than me and stuff
as I look forward to the next generation
but when you actually think about what
people deal with in their life I deal
with global economies they deal with
large social networks they deal with
human health and I actually think that
the level of complexity that we say that
the biosphere has is actually no greater
than many other things that were quite
used to talking about this science
festival for example very often he has
discussions about quantum mechanics and
cosmology right and you know if we can
actually learn so much about Mars I
don't really see that we can't also do
the same for for here it's not that
complicated there's a big difference
here because if you need to you know
humans execute things like global health
you want to eradicate smallpox humans
have to eradicate smallpox and if you
want to try to understand or manipulate
especially manipulate the global economy
humans have to do that but humans don't
really have to do anything about the
natural world or earth systems they
function really well without us and you
don't have to understand everything
about them as if you need to manipulate
them
to make them be okay what you have to do
is basically stop wrecking them and
leave enough space for other creatures
to simply leave live their lives and
further processes of existence in life
and survival and evolution to just
continue on their own they do very very
well without us we're the we're the
problem we don't have to understand it
in order to solve it we just have to let
it be that's that's you know as an
ecologist that's what I understand
is that we we don't need to understand
it to fix it it's infinitely interesting
to try to understand it that's why I am
also an ecologist because it's
infinitely interesting but we don't have
to understand the Amazon to let it exist
we just need to let it exist not cutting
it down is a good start for instance the
fish that are recovering in in our local
orders we have a number of populations
fish that are recovering as a result of
recent changes in the law and the
management and they're not recovering
because we're managing the fish they're
recovering because we're not killing
them as fast as we used to and it turns
out this is an interesting scientific
fact if you stop killing them they don't
die as fast that's the one thing that we
are learning so let me ask you a
question about personalities mine or
Silvius or well yes and all of us your
notebook is called beyond words what
animals think and feel and you've said
that you wanted to figure out not just
what was at stake but who was at stake
what do you mean by that when you what
do you mean who's at stake what I mean
who's at stake well we live on a planet
with a lot of other company and we don't
usually think of it that way we think
that there's us and that the whole world
is for us and everything is about us and
that all these other things are just out
there and they have names like macaw or
chimpanzee and those are all
interchangeable they're just like
marbles that were shaken on a board you
know
you can move them around one is the same
as the other and none of that is
actually how it is these are also living
things which to a greater and lesser
extents try very hard to stay alive
try very hard to keep their babies alive
they know where they are they understand
where the food is where the water is who
their friends are who their enemies are
what the dangers are what they need to
do to make a living and try to survive
just like all the rest of us and if you
look at every single animal where
individual differences in behavior have
been looked for behaved differences when
confronted with the same stimulus which
is in other words personality something
happens you behave differently than I
behave you react differently than you
react that's personality every single
species where personality has been
looked for from whales elephants Apes to
spiders it has been found so that's what
I mean by whom you're talking about in
these species or the individuals within
the species the individuals within the
space we missed that picture receivers
we just saw they all look the same and
those kang-ho is the everybody here
looks more or less the same to a lot of
white faces I notice oh my god they all
do look the same look at they have two
eyes and they have air on top so they
must all be the same there's no
differences between this whatever this
group here is anybody who has a dog or
or a horse or anything like you get to
know an individual of any other species
what you realize is that they are all
individuals that's that's chula that's
my that's my little dog one of my two
little doggies she's one of the best
friends I've ever had and I mean that
seriously I'm not joking she's one of
the best friends I've ever had she has a
fantastic personality we have another
dog named Jude and his personality is
totally different and if you've got to
know things like wolves or elephants or
zebras or in the case of a friend of
mine who used to work here in on the
biodiversity side he had a couple of
tortoises in his office for years and he
told me all about the differences in
personality how
that one loved his secretary how that
one have used to bust into the
refrigerator and then and then be very
very quiet munching the lettuce because
because he knew that if he got caught
the door would get shut on him okay but
who ever gets to see stuff like that
because we don't watch we think it's all
about us and that they're all exactly
the same yeah they're not but these
schools of fish we see underwater so be
assured if there's not personality
differences between those uniformed fish
those sardines that taste so yummy when
you difference between personalities you
bet really you reminding me of a story I
heard about 30 years ago when I was
being taught out of school dived on into
the Caribbean and this scuba diving
teacher claimed that there was a
flounder that was very naughty and loved
to come along and break away from the
group she took us down our group swam
around and that flounder came up and
started behaving a very unique but you
find us also an individual fish I think
I had an awakening first time I had a
chance to actually live underwater stay
underwater in the same place for a
couple of weeks got to know that fish
that lived in that area that moray eel
that was over in a certain part of the
reef five angelfish that lived in
different places but they got together
early in the morning just at dawn and
they traveled around they piled around
together and I I mean it just came into
focus for me I should have noted known
this hasn't seen it before but I started
looking at the faces of fish and I still
think people now into aquariums I say
now you see that that that bunch of
macro lat like the monterey aquarium or
the New England aquit whatever
you look closely and you can actually
you can see they're all different they
really are and it's not just the
appearance late for those stripes like
on zebras if you look at them carefully
no two zebra has identical stripe
patterns no two black cats are exactly
alike if you really look at them but
it's the personality too they behave
differently come to think of it with
humans if we have a group of other
humans that we want to be mean to we'll
decide that they are all like this yeah
it is the same it is the same with
animals it's just that we're just
starting to wake up to that fact we've
woken up to it more or less with human
beings
why did scientists resist this obvious
fact well until about 1960
no one ever studied the behavior of wild
animals people who studied elephants
before Iain douglas-hamilton they shot
them and then they measured their they
soared their teeth and half to see how
old they were and you know things like
that
those those were studies in wild animals
the other thing is that what people
started to formally studying the
behavior of wild animals they had to
strip away a few centuries of caricature
is a ssin that you know foxes are clever
grasshoppers are lazy so the scientists
said well okay none of that we're going
to just wipe the slate but then they
said well we have no way of knowing and
we can't they started making all these
rules we can't say that they are like we
can't say that they are having a fight
we have to say that they are behaving
agonistic aliy they made up all these
new names like agonistic instead of
fight they're fighting over territory of
fighting over mates but they're not
fighting only humans man only humans do
everything humans do everything else
that does the exact same thing for the
exact same reason it's not the same
thing which is totally absurd completely
non-scientific because guess what the
organizing principle of biology is that
everything is related through evolution
that's the organizing principle so the
idea that we are categorically different
in all these behaviors is not scientific
at all and it's patently absurd so
there's that there's that problem and
the other problems we just you know pet
lovers and things like that we we see
with our pets that there are individual
differences but very few people know
anything about the lives of wild animals
how many wild animals do you get to
watch oh it's very hard to do it wasn't
done all the people who are who started
it Jane Goodall Iain douglas-hamilton
George shallow those be they're all
still alive and still working that's how
new it is
you did something with a wolf you can
you can tell what an animal is thinking
in three in three ways that are exactly
equivalent to how you can tell what
another person is thinking because you
you can't exactly know what another
person is think that's why we say how
are you because you don't know so with
other animals is basically three ways
there's evolution as a guiding principle
there's the biology of the nervous
system and there is the logic of
behaviors you see the workings of the
mind and the logic of behaviors if a if
an animal runs from something dangerous
that's because they're running from
something dangerous if they act
frightened it's because the emotion that
makes them run is fright and etc on and
on there's plenty of examples oh love it
now with the wolves you can really see
the lives of individuals in the stories
of simply the wolves of Yellowstone Park
because in Yellowstone is the only place
in the world where wolves have in fact
been watched through the course of their
lives and there are fantastic stories
about individual wolves there was a wolf
number 21 he was called the super wolf
he distinguished himself from other
wolves because his behavior and his
personality were extraordinary he lived
at a time of very high density in the
population the Wolves had lots of
encounters with other packs rumors a lot
of fighting that went on and this one
particular wolf 21 never lost a fight
but never killed a vanquished rival both
of those things are unique no other wolf
ever did that he died on his own terms
of old age by walking up to a rendezvous
site where they used to wait for their
pups and he laid down right there and he
died while the rest of the pack walked
away across the valley no other wolf
ever did anything like that
he was mated to an extraordinarily
aggressive female wolf who was very
abusive to her own daughters a wolf pack
is just a nuclear family the alphas are
just the breeding male and female and
the rest of the pack is their children
when the children become adolescents
they leave to try to get their own
footing in the world just like we do
that's why we have wolves in our homes
in a form of dogs and not chimpanzees
because they live in nuclear families
and chimpanzees don't wolves can live
with us that's why we have them in our
homes so this very abusive female was
murdered by her own daughters one night
when she was on her way to a daughter's
den probably to kill the daughters pups
and and they they she did that once
before and they weren't going to let it
happen again no other time has that ever
been observed there was another wolf
that they called Casanova and he was a
very flaky male wolf who specialized in
sneaking affairs with with the daughters
of various packs and he he would always
run away from fights later in his life
he became the Alpha of a pack he and he
inherited the Alpha position because a
male died and he stayed
he died fighting in defense of his
children and allowed them all to escape
that fight and live so you see the
trajectories now these wolves that are
on here this this is a male named 7:55
he was shot by hunters he was the he was
the mate of a very famous female wolf
called oh six the most famous wolf that
has ever lived the only non-human that
ever got her on obituaries in the New
York Times she was shot when they
wandered out of Yellowstone he was shot
a few days later and that was the most
stable pack in the park at the time so
and everything fell apart on them the
trajectory of all the children's lives
totally changed right there this is the
local news that was listening to it just
last night it from five o'clock in other
words not getting the general idea
you're finding enormous variety
personality intelligence right and
that's vitals we are defined as
individuals by our relationships to
other individuals and so are many other
kinds of creatures to the extent that we
never have suspected before we're just
starting to learn and that's really the
frontier of our whole relationship with
the rest of the living world as far as
I'm concerned all right [ __ ] your work
is on environmental consequence finally
you get to say something well the
system's guy here you're working on the
environmental consequences of the loss
of biodiversity how in heaven's name can
you measure that or you don't even know
what and how many species exist on the
planet we keep hearing that we only know
about 20% of the species well there are
lots of things we don't know very much
about but we still go around and measure
them so we can measure the temperature a
body or an object or liquid and we don't
actually know very much about each of
the individual atoms or the vibrational
energies and the electrons around them
but we have this number because they in
general this is hot or general this is
cold without worrying about all that
complexity we do the same thing with all
of the stars and planets in the universe
and we can do the same thing with the
biota
but I hear what a hair talks like this
about you know and these are pictures I
took which is you know hard for me to to
think about because I grew up in
Brooklyn and in that purse I visit
Anthony nature was something you see on
television but so with Star Trek them if
I had my choice I'd watch Star Trek
right but at some point I went to
rainforest because a professor took me
to and I've always seen biodiversity as
the full collection of all of the
organisms I think of the world as a
trillion ton system that's just the
carpet it's probably a hundred trillion
tons if we were to throw in some of the
other elements and thinking about what
you said five hundred billion tons of
that trillion tons system our microbes
in I'm sure each micro has its own
personality
trillions of that but but and you know
that my concern is that you know I can
look back and think of that trillion
that 500 billion tons of mass of
microorganisms and recognize that they
are absolutely critical to the
environment to the air that we breathe
to the stability of the system marine
terrestrial if freshwater doesn't matter
right now we have molecular tools which
are allowing us to see the microbial
communities and in ways that we've never
imagined we could do even just ten or
twenty years ago and the ocean is
amazing the microbial diversity ocean
he's staggering sad thing he didn't
actually see these things there's just
sequences of DNA and I actually started
to go down the path of studying
microorganisms because I was feeling
guilty is what I traveled I mostly was
interested in the Lions and the zebra
and the birds and so forth and I never
really saw the microbes with it to be
honest what I realized that would mean a
life of studying sequences on the
computer or looking through a microscope
at little glowing dots I I still sort of
Spain working with the whole system but
mention the environmental things we've
been talking about like ocean
acidification which can contribute
- you know the demise and many of our
coral reef systems climate change mean
much of this has to do with the the
dreaded biogeochemistry is like taking
three or at birds and putting them
together and so scientists love to do
but the but then if I really want to
understand that at some point I have to
stop you know thinking about the
individual organisms and their
individual behaviors cuz that resonates
with me a lot which is where I always
like showing pictures of wildlife that
I've taken and my two cats are among my
favorite you know species in the world
but I think I've never seen an insect
that I wasn't fascinated by like my
degrees in zoology my PhD is in zoology
I've never seen you know you see
microorganisms under the microscope how
many didn't have got the chance to see
protozoa I get the feeling the attained
us in the direction of looking at
systems more than individual species and
they may have charismatic species to lie
on the Panda things we can see but I
take it that you're you are suggesting
that getting over this enormous
catastrophe to be brought on ourselves
and their fellow inhabitants of the
planet means that we also have to look
at systems not just individual species
is that right we give it exactly when I
see these species that I love these he's
the pictures I've taken taken after the
secretary bears one of my favorite
numbers of all time um and as I said I
love insects but I always take my cavern
I take the time to look around because I
love the living world but when I see
each of those animals even when I see
your dog even when I see you and when I
see you I realize that right now we are
contributing to this system one of the
exercises I do in classes I don't have a
computer but I'll take out something
like this
and say imagine that there 8.7 million
parts in here I really value the phone
or my computer even though I actually
don't know very much about the millions
of parts that are probably in here one
of the things I do is I often take off
the back and start pulling parts out of
it and then you know if you ask somebody
how much they'll pay for the iPhone
right now that might be a few hundred
bucks if I take one part out of the
iPhone
nobody wants to buy it right if I take
two of these aren't you know they might
want to pay me to dispose of it yeah I
mean they want me to pay to dispose of
it and the thing is that I value the
iPhone now a bit of a geek I mean I love
my Raspberry Pi don't how many have
raspberry PI's out there and I actually
think a transistor is a beautiful thing
right when I look at a neatness system I
see an iPhone when I see those schools
of fish I see them as all connected into
this big system we love systems we love
automobiles we love televisions we love
social networks we love our country our
country's a big complex system all of
you parts of our country if you know we
can appreciate our individual roles when
we all go out to vote for our
interesting pair of presidential
candidates is coming up you have the
opportunity to participate in that
system or not and that's why that's why
I really think that you have to struggle
to retain the power of appreciating the
individual sort of miracle that every
organism is including a virus in the
ocean to the system itself well Alyssa I
believe we have a chart that talks about
the functional biodiversity functional
diversity in fact in general it allows
us to us because I think your your
marina stores how to think about all of
it and every scale all at once that's
the traitor
you know I got a chance in 2012 with my
colleagues to write her in paper for
some 20 years of research that had been
going on trying to connect biological
diversity with the biosphere and all its
by geochemical processes and so since
they let me make this this picture I
actually sat down they had great fun of
doing a drawing because you know we all
love to draw right and so what better
images try to capture is what was said
here all organisms are related to one
another by our evolutionary history I
find incredible pride in that I'm
surprised how Summerlee just
surveys find that awkward I'm you don't
actually find myself to be really proud
to be related to the tardigrade or the
best maneuver for the zebra whether pry
applet you'll also than I do my brother
nobody's not here right really probably
related to them and then you know there
are these environmental filters as
they're called that then determine where
organisms are going to be right so fish
of course will be in marine systems but
you'll find organisms that are adapted
to the cold living in the polar
environments organisms that are adapted
to tropical the dry system is living in
tropical rainforests or deserts and
that's what this is trying to show i'm
not question what i'm looking at yet
tell us what because people here can't
see the small okay what is it a general
a picture of okay so at the at the very
bottom down here is the is the
evolutionary tree of a life and all of
the organisms are connected by that they
then are spread out over that 3.5
billion years of history they wind up
being spread out over the planet
depending on where they're best adapted
to and that's the next layer up we see
the bat all the way on one side all the
way to a marine organism on the other
and a bunch of other plants and animals
and microorganisms perhaps they're there
as well but hard to see and then you
assemble them all into systems tropical
systems desert systems polar systems
marine systems whether the intertidal or
coral reefs and that those systems are
like the systems i was describing before
the other than what they're taking the
what we call inorganic compounds carbon
dioxide and nitrous oxide and basically
all of the elements of the of our world
and making them into complex organic
compounds and then also turning them
back into
so that's what the upper part is showing
you look at the diversity of lines it
actually is connected to the greenhouse
gases that are in the atmosphere so what
this has to do with being stewards of
all of this life which we want to be
what's why we're here it's just making
us aware of how very interconnected it
all is yes and so that's why I again
differing with with my my friends here
um I actually feel that we do need to
know about the system war not a lot but
enough you know so when I graduated I
didn't have a job so whether I bought a
little sports car because you know I
wasn't responsible but what was great
about it he's dead I went to the store
and I found the Chilton manual for an
MGB right in he have it was full of
diagrams and instructions and wiring and
I was able to restore that not
functioning car right I feel right now
stewards you know stewards or or or of
spaceship earth and it's making funny
noises right it's a little warm things
are bleaching stuff is disappearing
parts are falling out and I go to the
back of there and I take out the the
manual and the pages are blank and it's
like it's got a list of parts like
you're how big less Museum as lists of
parts but doesn't tell me all how the
thing out about isn't working you know
and if it's not can I fix it can it be
restored what do I need you I'm not
asking for much I'm just asking for a
repair manual and then I say okay well
I'm gonna go to the toolbox what's my
toolbox in my toolbox
I have a sledgehammer and a crowbar
right this is the tools we work with
tube to do on this planet and it just
doesn't strike me as a very smart way to
go what I and my colleagues is study the
relationship between biodiversity that
biologically complex system there and
the atmosphere and the lithosphere and
the hydrosphere he's trying to
understand how all of those parts
together make that system function and
say so I would like I would like I would
read somebody asked me he said you're
kind of an angry fellow
why is it you want I said I just want a
blueprint of mother that's all I want
and I said I feel if we have the human
genome if we're getting pretty close to
mapping out all of the stars you were
able to do pretty fantastic things like
landing a small robot on Mars and
talking to it I think we can get a
blueprint of Earth why not we're part of
it well I'm my goodness because usually
when we hear about this thank you and
you just sound exciting as hopefully
that's a big problem
it's an enormous a complex problem and
up until now people who don't want us to
think about this say oh it's too complex
for humans to understand but you're
telling us we can get our arms around it
after all Ed Wilson and others have
started the online encyclopedia of life
and the aim is to get every single
species online and detailed so any
middle school kid can go into it it's a
fantastic resource especially did the
what was it the census of marine life
ten years
funded in part by the Sloan but also by
an NSF and other foundations just they
just spent ten years I think right so
what education the human race couldn't
manage this yeah that's very important
census of marine life did a great job of
showing us what we don't know Richard
was great if cataloguing what we do know
that it also gave us lives how much more
there is to know especially in the ocean
but it's also on the land we're finding
new things in Central Park for heaven's
sakes when you start looking in Central
Park
nope and the new stations are [ __ ]
center-right indeed so let's take a
moment to consider the thing that
worries me about the idea that well look
you didn't need the manual in order to
know not to drive the car into a wall
right you don't know me very well
okay perhaps that may be true maybe
that's a bad example
I'm I'm all for learning everything we
possibly can learn because that helps us
appreciate where we are what we have in
quite frankly it puts us it gives us
more perspective and it puts us in a
more realistic frame of mind about what
we are and are not here but a lot of
people seem to think I've heard this for
a long time that we need to know more
before we can address these problems and
when it comes to the living world we we
know plenty about what not to do what to
stop doing what to get going on and
there is no reason to delay we're way
behind as it is we're creating problems
faster than we can possibly fix them and
we understand mostly why we're creating
those problems in the broad-stroke even
though we don't understand a lot about
the system so while I want everybody to
understand as much as possible about all
these systems glorify in it respect it
enjoy it understand it well enough to to
give good advice about what to do and
not do yes absolutely
but not wait at all not wait at all
because that the time for action on a
lot of things was decades ago so that's
I think that's the tension here and the
points that I think we're both sort of
and I like winding is in order to
cheerful bad news in on top of all of
this the news about global warming is
rapidly getting worse and worse it's not
the elephant the room it's the elephant
we're all inside of and every species is
affected one way or another by global
warming and as we said at the beginning
it's accelerating extinction rates very
quickly there could be a runaway process
at any moment in which there's so much
heat that it starts a tipping point of
accelerating heat that we can't control
so aren't we out of time on this them
let me just ask one narrow question
about this for example to think about
possible solutions for a moment there's
a lot of talk about stopping the carbon
emissions we hear a lot of talk about
biofuels as a way to eliminate the
addition of carbon to the atmosphere
which means it immoral faster what do
you think of biofuels well so I'm I have
a peculiar perspective on it in the
sense that I think all of us really
would like to be more green as we say in
our activity so we lower our
environmental footprint but you think
about biofuels is we already know that
things like ethanol made from corn or
cordgrass and so forth are sugarcane
actually releases more carbon into the
atmosphere but that aside I guess my pet
peeve about this is that you know I was
in India last week and flying back I'm
very impressed with the Air France and
it's it's a French food and they the
airplane which is actually fuel
excuse me by this really clean clear
liquid running out of walk homes it's my
water here and when I think about it
that fuel actually is just dead plants
that I mean it's we are in our planes
and our cars and in fact in our weapons
of destruction p.m. the fuel we're using
actually is just a bunch of dead plants
so we talked about decarbonizing the
energy sector I think that's what we
really want to focus on its
controversial because you know nuclear
energy doesn't involve carbon but do we
want to go down that route but you saw
pictures of windmills and their
potential for wave power potential for
solar power and so forth I just think
that biofuels is keeping us in the burn
the dead plant syndrome right so it's
more of the same mistake with you making
and the coughing has been going on a lot
in New York City lately because of
polymers has been higher than ever
anticipated by scientists about five
years ago that pollen was going to get
much more difficult in
right now so I think I just got choked
up about your sad where it's about thing
that's personal is the problems what do
we do about how bad the news is we have
to we have to figure out how to look at
it and figure out how to organize all
the things we know we need to do to stop
it
what is Sylvia what is your best hope in
terms of what we can do about it in fact
let's look at something that Ed Wilson
has been pointing out to us we couldn't
be here tonight
Gorongosa National Park in Mozambique
where he's put a lot of time in lately
he is under the guidance of Leo Wilson
and others the great National Park was
devastated by war its animals nearly
wiped out is being restored and now you
give 8 your half a chance and is turning
out they come back right go too far but
giving nature of a break is the smartest
thing we can do protect what remains of
the natural systems that are working
restore what we can it's so logical when
you truly face up to the problem ed
Wilson suggests at least half the earth
should be left alone let nature do her
thing let the life-support system
functions function respect the ocean as
if your life depends on it because it
does the most important thing we extract
from the ocean or from nature generally
is not the wood from trees or the fish
from the seeds our existence that's what
we extract that is the greatest value if
you like to breathe you will listen up
right that's what it's all about
and Ed Wilson on his 80th birthday at
the World Science Festival a few years
ago
made the comment that we're living in
nature slip through our fingers what
he's really saying is that nature could
let us slip through hers right we often
hear the phrase we've got to save the
planet but the truth is the planet is
going to be just fine it's filling back
up to greenhouse conditions which has
been in before and likes very much and a
lot of species disappear it will evolve
some more but we won't necessarily be
there well all right now let's bring out
two more participants but if you had the
chance to see the virtual reality film
collisions before the program began and
you'll be able to see it afterwards if
you didn't see it already so she's an
acclaimed artist and director known for
her immersive installations and films
which explore the connections between
people in the natural world
please welcome Lynette Woolworth and
finally we're lucky to have an
anthropologist Jennifer Newell who is
curator Pacific Islands here
anthropologist here at this museum she's
researching climate change and its
impact on the lives and cultures of
Pacific Islands
Jennifer you well thank you very much
for joining us thank you um Lynette
you've brought us this amazing story
that we've seen in this virtual reality
film that you made your calling in
collisions what collides in that film
well what collides initially is some
theories or and the modern people's sort
of long term relationship to place
with our technological development so if
you haven't seen this film
Neri standing there it's amaru man the
man who lived in a part of Australia
that was people didn't want for grazing
or growing so they were left alone for a
lot longer than many of the Aboriginal
people of Australia and their first
contact was in the 1960s 1960s they
lived on till then as every generation
heard before but in the 1950s Britain
was testing atomic bombs in the outback
of Australia seven atomic tests and
Denari was the motto were nomadic people
who was moving through part of that area
unbeknownst to Britain they took an area
that was had a trade route running
through it so people from other tribal
groups could move through the area was
five times the size of Great Britain one
man in a four-wheel drive was driving
around trying to make sure that no one
would come in contact with those tests
and he didn't succeed so in the 1950s
Neri was walking through there and what
he collided with his whole world vision
collided with our technology and what he
thought that was is why that film exists
when he saw this blaster he did not know
was an atomic bomb yeah so until then
after Mario who I've worked with now for
since 2012 2011 they've thinkin's their
first contact stories and recent and so
been very in living memory everything
they saw that was new they could only
relate to what they already knew so the
intervention of something into that
worldview that was unknown could only be
read according to the note so when I
asked Neary what did you think that was
he said
we thought it was the spirit of our gods
rising up to speak with us and what did
he think after you explained to him what
it was and showed him the shell Moses
Oppenheimer well when I met Mary he
already knew what that was because I met
him four years ago but for a period of
time that I don't know the length of
yeah he ate kangaroos that were wiped to
the ground by the aftershock he thought
his God was giving him a gift so the
modern men especially nomadic hunters
spent all of their time trying to catch
kangaroos in the way that in that way of
consciousness that you would talk about
watching a mob of kangaroos seeing which
was the old to seeing which was pregnant
seeing which was young choosing the
oldest one knowing that that was the one
to take so but here in front of them
were a whole lot of leveled kangaroos so
they thought God had given them some
special gift and a lot of people got
sick as a result of and he told that
they took those kangaroos and ate them
were irradiated and it made people oh
this is all or all this is not written
down anyway he said it's not even known
very well in Australian history and many
people still don't know that Britain
tested until we bombs in the outback of
history gun drops seven atomic bombs on
top of the land I understand there was
only one sign warning and there was
going to happen and it was in English
how many Aboriginal people died so it's
not known because because of this one
man was was given the responsibility to
make sure that there were no peoples
there the traditional people of this
area the Maryland Georgia people so as I
said Meera was a maru man from Western
Australia he was moving through the
train route the motto were driven off
that land by various processes
I'm sorry that Marilyn get Jarrett sure
we're even effects but one one British
man was given the responsibility
it was Australian one Australian man was
given responsibility
he was Australian where's this story
forgive me for asking this kind of short
this story has deep meaning for what the
purpose that the title of this meeting
here is how to be stewards of the earth
is it to you an example of a doctor when
I talked with Mary about this story so
he know many his later understands this
was an atopic tips understands the
implications of that but he comes from a
group of people whose entire way of
thinking is multi generations
multi-generational so stewardship for
them means he does this gesture when I
talk to him about this he does adjuster
which is like passing something around
the back of him and bringing something
forward this beautiful gesture what that
means is these ones are always going and
these ones are always arriving and you
have to be aware that these ones are on
their way their whole way of thinking is
about the ones who are on their way and
that's what he says in this film
so to drop an atomic bomb that's going
to irradiate the food sources the
foliage the land for thousands and
thousands of years is eating us see to
him it reminds me of the Iroquois
believed you always have to be thinking
about seventh-generation in the future
when you make any decisions of any
consequence because they're on their way
and everything that everyone on this
panel has been talking about makes sense
from that perspective how much you take
what resources you leave if you think in
terms of seven generations or seventy
then you are careful about what you take
on what you leave because you want
everything to be maintained
and that's why I'm interested in working
with the model because their way of
thinking embodies this long-term
generational thinking which means they
use their resources very very carefully
all of the profit minded bankers and
investors who are putting constructions
and other obstacles in the way of
natural growth on the planet might not
be so inclined to listen to him no
certainly not and they right now have to
do with a mining company there's 200 at
the moment that I know of there's 200
like the leases on uranium mines in
Australia so it's more extractive
resources as soon as that resource
starts to rise in in it's worth like
digging up the country where that will
happen for another reason these people
are saying no we don't want that thing
touched and it's also one of them if not
the largest coal exporting country in
the world yeah and you know we've just
allowed another coal mine is going to
impact the Great Barrier Reef the Adani
coal mine bridging the dredging of that
of that of that coal moving through
close to that reef so we have a lot of
responsibility in this country to try
and take more care it's such an enormous
problem the enormity of this all over
the place a few of the points around the
planet in animals in the sea in these
systems from the large to the small
Jennifer you just come back from the
Pacific Islands from LA but also I
remember in 2009 I was interviewing the
Micronesian ambassador to the UN was
pleading with everybody before the
Copenhagen conference to cut the limit
of emissions at 2.0 above pre-industrial
and he said it was never going to happen
and he looked at me and gave me the most
poignant somebody I've ever captured on
camera where he just looked under the
Cameron said the world has written this
off that was Micronesia
seven years ago what can you report to
us about what's happening in the Pacific
Islands Kira boss we've heard of in
other places as well as Seychelles what
what do you have to tell us about all of
that what's happening when the rising
sea levels which by the way recent
science says is coming much faster than
we thought quite possibly six is it six
meters six feet six feet but this
endlessly fast because 15 of the 20
largest cities in the world are on sea
level
Inessa cities to say nothing of these
ancient thousands of year old cultures
what you had report to us from the
Pacific Islands so I can put a lot from
the Pacific Islands
there are many islands which are very
low-lying so lots of coral atolls such
as the Marshall Islands karabasan and
others which because they're low-lying
coral atolls are often very you're just
a little way above sea level and the
Marshall Islands which is made up of 29
coral atolls which is also comprised of
about a thousand islands at no point is
at higher than six feet and there's been
one foot of sea level rise over the last
30 years but as you've just said that
level is increasing so what happens
every month every two months if they're
especially high tide and that now
reaches often right across the at all
right across the island because these
islands usually only about a mile across
at the most people have been living here
about 2500 years this is their their
ancestral homeland leaving is not
anything that anyone can really really
comprehend you losing their land is not
something they can comprehend as the
very powerful poet kata general
Kitchener has said we have never wanted
to leave we are nothing without our
islands there are many people in the
Marshall Islands who have been able to
represent their plight in international
fora like the UN
Tony to broom recently was at cop21 in
Paris and he I think there was at that
event that um after he had presented the
case near that if we agree to more than
two degrees warming then that's the
death warrant for for our peoples our
for our culture for our place for our
land I think it was one of the
representatives from India who said who
cares and so that's what they're up
against right here's just a little small
people small islands they're small on
the map
why should we care you'd be something
little you lose overt we're all
interconnected as we've just seen we're
way too connected with the species of
this planet or it connects with the
other people at this planet these
independent nations what are they going
to do well what are they already doing
isn't it true that some of them are
already being wiped out as nations
in effect yes there may be there are
Islanders who've had to leave for the
cat Rhode Islanders have had to leave
and they've moved to de Bougainville
they're from the PNG government the
proper New Guinean government has given
them a small parcel of land trying to
recreate some sort of life there for
themselves but there are an ocean people
and it's very difficult to try and live
in this very new environment what's
happening in other places is they're
they're trying to come up with plans for
the future that might involve migrating
in community groups to suitable suitable
places elsewhere
Marshall Islanders are particularly
tightly connected to the u.s. because of
the compact of free association that's
been set up because of the the 46
nuclear weapons that we nuclear bombs
that were set off in the Marshall
Islands in the Cold War era so because
of that the US has an ongoing
relationship with the Marshall Islands
and Marshall Islanders were able to come
and live and work in the US and that
means that a lot of martial artists are
considering moving here many have moved
to places like Springdale Arkansas where
it's zero it's a cheap kind of lifestyle
of people are able to maintain
themselves
that came to keep their community um and
what about their economy for example in
fishermen they're told this kind of fish
yes so there are difficulties with the
international community not really
understanding or bothering to understand
the local economies local ways of
managing resources and often coming in
and instituting a broad scale marine
protection area or some other
restrictions without really
understanding what the locals have been
doing and managing for thousands of
years so there needs to be more
conversations there needs to be more
listening to what the islanders are
saying because they're saying a lot it's
just that the international community is
not really listening I think that's one
of the key things we can be doing and
I'm noticing that what are set by many
people to read the two great existential
threats facing humanity in our survival
nuclear holocaust this happens either
all at once or not at all any global
warming or both happening to them and
whatever it is because they weren't he
had nearby nuclear tests as well yes
that's right sir in places like the
Marshall Islands where they have had a
history of of large-scale disaster and
large scale moving up relocation from
homelands to to new places they've got
some experience of the kinds of
disasters and problems that they're
having to face now and so they've been
resilient people but but then again they
also know that they do need they need
help from the international community
and so many island governments and
Island individuals are asking for help
we're at a very important watershed and
also we have the beginning of enough
knowledge as a unified species if we can
get over our distractions and Wars it's
knowing knowing is the starting point as
never before as I say we know what we
could not know could not understand
there's been a revolution we've learned
or literally learned more
in the last half-century then during all
preceding history because we have a
means to discover that did not exist
with us in the skies above or the depths
of the ocean or within our own bodies
though and to be able to Carly and look
at patterns we have the capacity to to
enlist computers to help us crunch the
numbers and look for answers to the
questions we posed and in fact it we
care that we can see the consequences -
of our behavior is is a really good
starting point but as we've been saying
there it is at lunchtime the next 10
years it could be literally the most
important in the next 10,000 years
but it's now and it is now we do all
have to act I think it's the last
generation which can actually do
anything to help actually save us as a
species and I think as you pointed out
we do have computers we can all do a lot
of personal activism we can all consume
less this is a crucial thing we all have
to consume less and care for and educate
ourselves more and as to what's actually
happening out there how we can help
actually care enough to make that happen
you know partly I work in the field I do
trying to you visual images of things
that I think it's hard to imagine I
think partly I'll focus on our own not
just our own families but our own
country is a limitation that we not
seeing the connection in the events that
are happening globally which is what
people have been talking about for us in
history we can't just concentrate on
what's happening to the Great Barrier
Reef we need to also be aware of the
fires in Alberta Canada we need to be
aware of the fires in Siberia in the
forests we need to be able to if we
could see what's occurring at one time
see what's Korean one time very
interesting phrase what do you all think
of the mainstream American media
covering this do you think it's been a
good job do you have any opinions about
it well for many years the mainstream
media has been lazy enough to think that
a good story is where you take the two
opposing views and you just put them
there and you don't sort through and see
which view is truer and which view is
nonsense which view has 90% of the
people who know anything about it saying
one thing in which view has two people
funded by some industry saying the
opposite thing that was incredibly
irresponsible and everybody did that for
a really long time the New York Times
even did that for a really long time
with with warming and climate change
everybody has stopped talking about the
world population problem as the complete
catastrophe that it is or the solution
to it the solution is that if you look
at the countries where the population
has stopped growing or is declining it's
where women are full citizens and they
can go to any school they feel like
going to or own a business or get a bank
loan that's the solution you don't have
to know a lot about ecology to fix that
problem that way no one talks about it
no one knows that this is what word
could only see that's the mosaic we
would see you solve that injustice you
solve the whole problem with the rest of
the living world it's unbelievable but
nobody nobody sees that it looks at that
and as far as what what now counts as
the mainstream media they incredibly
partisan echo chamber that was enabled
when record when Reagan did away with
the Fairness Doctrine that tree
the airwaves says the public property
that's just a total total disaster in
total joke and it's gotten us where we
are it's gotten us exactly where we are
we're just about out of time she last
saw from you a quick thought about our
we do got all this well I think you use
the word I actually agree with you I you
said it really well I actually think
that this generation is of amazing
generation it's empowered like no
generation before it we have the
knowledge we have the tools but what you
said was that we're distracted that's
where the media and I think plays well
because the media feeds that distraction
I mean once once once we focus on
something we can do amazing things but
if we're distracted and we're gonna done
listen honey I'm afraid we're out of
time
our guests will be here for a little bit
if you have questions for them please
come up and ask them but no oh look
that's what they're here for
I'm sorry we haven't had more time to
listen to it but we've been hearing
about a general problem that we're all
wrestling with because if you just look
at the newspaper today that columns
today describing how grave this
onrushing complexity of a disaster is we
know we're just beginning to figure out
how we're going to get organized all
right well folks Carl will be signing
books that you can buy over where the
bar was and our experts will be here as
long as they can possibly stay when your
buttonhole them and ask them what you
want to ask them thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]